Is he your claim that it's standard or >> Hang tight. Peace
go. We can talk in a second. So, Taylor so
>> Okay, what what label to make you happy? So, I don't
trigger you with the wrong >> He's actually illiterate.
I I was joking earlier. I didn't know that this came up. He's
actually illiterate. >> I feel like a an actual anger.
Like I I kind of want to I I want to like break a keyboard or
something. >> You are making bad arguments. You are not
being specific in your language at all. You are messing up massively.
>> I've heard the liberal nerd episode is really good.
They're going hard after Taylor Lorenz. I think they're going
to go hard on the chorus stuff, too. And
I think they're going to continue to get embarrassed on it. >> A
powerful liberal dark money group is secretly funding some of
the biggest Democratic influencers on the internet. The program
is being funded by a powerful liberal dark money group called
the 1630 Fund that is working with chorus. The 1630 Fund is distributing
as much as $8,000 per month to influencers. Rather than launching
the program as a public-facing initiative, however, where creators
could openly and transparently use the funds to invest in their
businesses, the program is being run in secret. Creators told
me that if they were even so much as to acknowledge they were
part of the program, the contract stipulated that they'd be kicked
out and essentially cut off financially. >> Let's uh let's
take a look. I don't want to focus on like the current sort of
chorus stuff. I I I did want to talk about your article a little
bit. If you don't mind. >> Sure. Let's do it. >> I
I just find it so funny. So, if you guys didn't cover the stuff
with us, ultimately what happened is they they had creators who
felt uncomfortable. And I think those creators voiced their their
discomfort.
And I don't think chorus was as responsive as they could have
been. I think chorus could have cut this article off by just
responding to the article
Like chorus didn't respond to Taylor's article. The article is
about how not only is it dark money going into chorus, it was
explicitly in the contracts not to disclose that you had gotten
this money from them. And that was weird. That's just weird to
have something in there that says don't disclose that you got
money from us. >> Well, my sense of of this particular
reporting is that I think you do have a slant and I think you
do I think your opinion is biased. >> My slant is is probably,
I mean as you can read from all my Wired reporting, it's against
dark money and it's it's it is a transparency. >> no, that's
not the slant that I'm >> You should have to say that you
have had multiple conversations with Hassan before Taylor. That's
what you should have to say. Taylor, when you refuse to
that you love Hassan?
That's a that's actually a mark against >> I think you
have an anti-establishment
slant. I think I think you've discussed
Anti-establishment slant? >> In certain Sure, on certain
issues. >> article, it's like really clear
that you have villains in the story and you have heroes in the
story and you have kind of a larger narrative that I think goes
that I think goes beyond this article, right? >> people
work Right, but like my name is on the top but as you know with
an investigation like this, especially one that went
Anti-establishment,
but the establishment in this case is Chorus? That's not what
anti-establishment
The establishment can't be Chorus here.
The entity that's funded by money that can't be disclosed, that's
the
>> It's the top but like 15 people worked on this story.
So >> I well, I understand that but like for example, so
you you assigned the label centrist to Olivia Juliana. >> Which
is how she self-identified.
>> No, she self-identifies as a progressive, right? >> No,
I from what I found from my original reporting back from the
New York Times back when I had interviewed her years ago, she
was identifying as a centrist Democrat. Back in Texas. That was
her whole thing as and >> In 20 in 2024?
>> Maybe it was whenever I spoke to her her which was a
lot quite a while ago. But to but just to be clear, she never
took issue with that. She never reached out for a correction
on that at all. We would have been happy to like if she had >> No, no,
I mean nonetheless that that that is an opinion, right? Subjective
It's a very >> No, she just told you that Olivia Juliana
gave her that label for herself, idiot. It's not subjective.
It's not It's the It's the label she gave. It's Hey, this is
how Hey, we're going to put you in the article. We're talking
to you. How do you want us to describe you? Well, I'm a centrist
Democrat. Okay, sounds good. Huh, well, isn't that subjective,
actually? Isn't that >> know. It was how she Well, first
of all, I think we can correctly identify people's political
sort of affiliations. For instance, if she's I thought Correct
me if I'm wrong on Olivia Juliana, and Olivia Juliana works for
Corus. Um but
her whole thing was that she was a Democrat in Texas, right?
Who had done a lot of work with like reproductive
>> Yeah, right. So, she focuses on abortion, LGBTQ+, climate,
voting rights. When I look at these sort of policy uh priorities,
that does not strike me as a centrist When I think of a centrist,
I think of Joe Manchin.
I think it's like Jared Polis in Colorado, right? If Olivia wants
to reach out and and we honestly the the thing that you're bringing
up mostly comes up on the right because for instance, when I've
covered Nick >> I would imagine if she's in Texas, she
[clears throat] probably wants to be called a centrist explicitly
because
she's in Texas. Like that she doesn't want to be She doesn't
want to be called like a progressive in Texas cuz I'm guessing
the label actually hurts you. >> How would you define How
would you define centrist? How would you define >> A Democrat?
A Democrat that's probably middle of the road, like a middle-of-the-road
Democrat. Like a Democrat that could operate in a in a red state,
probably, and a blue state, maybe equal like, you know, somebody
that sort of appeals to >> This is maybe the one thing
that is really hard to get used to if you are just somebody who
is not used to engaging in online politics a lot, it's very difficult
to get used to the idea that there are some things in terms of
framing a conversation that you should just say, "No, I'm not
going to go any further on that. No, thank
All you say is I didn't do a deep dive into her politics. She
referred to herself as a centrist, a Gen Z centrist, and that's
what I referred to her as cuz it wasn't central to the article.
It didn't matter in the article >> Well, that's a very,
very broad >> kind of a like what the centrism itself
as I think about it sitting here,
there's a kind of identified more Schumer oriented Democrat,
more moderate Democrat. It is kind of vague, right? It's it's
a kind of vague term. >> hasn't Yeah, I think I wouldn't
say that Cori has I mean Cori has made content with Schumer like
I don't I I guess it's I I would say it's a very vague term.
It's probably the most broad term because I don't think we want
to get it again like too specific. >> The important thing
here Taylor is to Hutch's point based on and I I found this when
I read your article too. You you use centrist as like a pejorative,
>> No, for this one we say that like when >> No, no,
in general you do. You you've used you don't like the Democrats
and you especially >> Oh my god, the insane Are we really
tone
>> Really? This is the the tone police. This is your substantial
first engagement, right? You actually are going to get into critique
and it's just tone policing? Dude.
I
This is rough to watch already. It's already very rough, man.
Just tone policing. Well, actually don't you like kind of use
centrist in a mean way? Don't you kind of like mean it meanly?
Well, yeah, but this was an article Wired. Like I'm not using
centrist as a It's just meant to be a descriptor. It's not relevant.
Weren't you like when you said centrist Olivia Giuliani, weren't
you saying like inhuman piece of [__] Olivia Juliana?
Isn't that kind of what you were like hinting at? No. No, I
I hope it gets better. >> I have opinions on certain issues.
I think it depends on the type of >> Do [laughter] you
use centrist as a pejorative? That's the question. You use centrist
as a pejorative, right? Like you you view these people as like
these feckless do nothings and like I'm not >> I think
you're completely putting words in my mouth that I have not said.
I think I don't like Chuck Schumer and a lot of like there's
a lot of what he says, but there's a lot of people that are quote-unquote
centrists that I absolutely respect and work with and that worked
on this article. Like there's people that >> Like but just
to be clear, this article went through so many editors that have
such a range of political beliefs. And I hear you that maybe
we disagree that that Olivia Juliana is classified as as we described
her a centrist Gen Z influencer who spoke at the 2024 DNC. >> That
that's not really that does not really that's beside the point.
I mean whether or not she disputed it. I think that I think if
most people Well, hang on. Just let me real quick. I'm I'm trying
to be I'm not trying to cut you off very much. So just let me
let me say what I like. I think I think if like a reasonable
person went to Olivia Juliana's feed and they saw her priorities,
I think that they would like colloquially
understand her to be just sort of sort of like a standard Gen
Z progressive Democrat. >> What is this germane to? Like
what issue is this actually relevant to? What is this What is
this meant to help you? What point are you making? What point
is it in service of? This is like quibbling. It's just totally
pedantic quibbling over something that's not substantial. It
doesn't even make a
It's like a waste of everybody's time.
Why would you bring Taylor Lorenz on and just be like, well,
"Did you not go and consume a significant portion of this woman's
TikTok feed to get the correct political label for her?" No,
we didn't, Hutch. Oh, why would we have done that? It's why you're
not a journalist, Hutch. It's why your stream sucks, Hutch. Like
we know. We know you focus on the wrong things, Hutch. You don't
have to tell me. We all know. >> What do you think about
Biden, Hutch? I mean, let's be honest, right? Like so if if Biden
were described [laughter] as a centrist Democrat >> Olivia
Juliana was a Biden dead-ender. So she absolutely is a Biden
Democrat.
>> No, no, no. Somebody >> AOC AOC
>> Biden's the most progressive president in my lifetime.
>> Biden dead-enders. >> Exactly. Yes, >> And
and Bernie Sanders
them as demo I guess they're not >> AOC is they're progressives,
right? They're progressives, right? That doesn't make them centrists.
>> I would call them democratic socialists,
>> Well, listen, if you be if you had to choose between
progressive and centrist to describe AOC and Bernie, what would
you choose? Like like I
I want to engage with the conversation they're having. But this
is this is my problem, right? It's a completely worthless conversation
to have. This is actually a total waste of time. I don't want
to skip through it because technically a lot of my stream is
making fun of people who waste people's time and are trying to
like intellectualize things that shouldn't be. It's kind of what
the content is. But holy this is like a total waste of This is
the dumbest thing to spiral on. This is the dumbest thing to
bring up. Bro, I thought Hutch was talking about all kinds of
things. Hutch did debates on this. He did all kinds of coverage
of the chorus article. How is this the first thing and the most
important thing that you want to spiral on? >> I don't
know. I it totally depends on the context of the article and
>> Yeah, like you're being >> Because Bernie has
been No, because look at what Bernie's been doing with his AI
>> Like like okay, you got me. You got me. I should have
spent, you know, an hour, two hours going through Livvi Juliana's
TikTok and I I will actually send a a note to Wired to label
her a progressive instead of a centrist.
What has changed? What has changed in anybody's life now? Literally
nothing. Who cares? >> Like I just >> Nobody would
call him a centrist. Nobody. Nobody would use that word. >> I
wouldn't call him progressive either on certain things. I I just
>> Well, I just I I don't understand what these words mean
anymore. I mean like more broadly more broadly said you said
that there were 90 Did you see a list of 90 people? Is that Is
that how many people you saw? >> So, just to be clear,
I I understand that you take issue with the way that editors
categorize
these people, but this is >> though. You're inserting an
>> an opinion. Well, this is Chuck Johnson saying that
us calling him a Holocaust denier is an opinion or us saying
that Tucker Carlson is a right-winger is an opinion. All we can
do is try to best reflect the ideology that often we use self-described
ideologies, but all we can do >> she self-describes as
a progressive at this point. So, that's that's where I'm a little
bit confused. >> maybe, but who I would say I would say
again, if you ask actual people that are further to the left
than her, they will say not. >> Well, that's the issue.
That's the >> Right, and that's the [laughter] issue. And
that's the issue. And that's the issue. And that's the issue.
>> No, but that but but that's the
>> Dude, uh
Why is Soy Pill co-signing this?
What is going on here? >> Like, I would be I would feel
humiliated doing this. Like, spiraling on something that makes
no difference whatsoever at >> But if you're going to take
issue with like random sort of characterizations, and again,
I understand >> think it's random. I think it was deliberate.
I think it was deliberate >> Okay, well, I guess >> you
get to there? I mean, like I mean, why don't you go there? Just
ask >> know with the copy editor. >> I'm trying to
have a conversation with her. I don't know why you're jumping
in >> Well, no, no, no, because it's kind of a stupid critique
to be like, "Hey, you know, centrist kind of the beholder." Like,
yeah, so Joe Biden would describe himself as a centrist Democrat,
correct? Yes or no? >> No, peaceful. That's the whole point
of >> Wait, wait, can you answer that first? Can you answer
that? Yes, the whole point is the framing. So, talk about the
framing. This is THERE'S GOT TO BE SOMETHING more substantial.
Because if you're if that's all that happened was the framing
was, "Oh, well, this person's a centrist." If that's literally
all that happened, and you're mad about the framing of this,
then you are a loser. >> The question The question you
should ask The question you should ask is, "Taylor, did you
The question that you should ask is, "Taylor, do you Were you
attempting to imply something nefarious when you use centrist
there? Were you trying to imply that they're aligned with the
DNC?"
listen, I Taylor, respectfully, >> Thank you. Thank you.
Peace goes Peace goes like, "Hey, you are having a totally worthless
conversation, Hutch, and Soy Pill."
Soy Pill is so confusing to me cuz sometimes he can be intelligent
and other times he's Hutch with that goofy >> Well, I think
it's important because I I do think that it was >> I'm
sorry you feel this way, but this is just completely unproductive.
I I mean, it's just completely unproductive. >> you're
you're becoming quite defensive and evasive right now. >> No,
it's frustrating because I am feel like I'm dealing with the
white nationalist because this is all I do all day is go back
and forth with the white >> It's all by choice, but it's
not cuz of that. Just so you know. >> ridiculous argument
where it's like, >> You think the questions that I asked
you amount to like being questioned by a white nationalist?"
>> I I would call you they are low chat.
>> They are low IQ, totally irrelevant questions that are
driving away from the actual meaningful reporting, Hutch. And
in that way, you are just like a total [__] skinhead
who is trying to press Taylor on something that's not germane
to the article. >> you listen? They are the exact same
the exact same words you're using the exact same method of of
saying, right? When you When we write about Tucker Carlson and
I've go gone back and forth with Tucker Carlson Carlson's team
on this exact issue, right? We'll say, "Well, we characterize
you as XYZ, far right, right? Far right is actually even more
common than the right with white nationalist." And every time
I write about a right-wing influencer and we say, "Well, we are
you know, whatever. Here's the article. Here we're asking you
for comment, blah blah blah blah blah." They will say, "I'm not
far right. I'm not far right. I'm progressive." In some cases,
they even say even Tim Pool types, "I'm actually progressive."
Okay, but >> Taylor, I I think that I I >> Just let
me Just let me finish. >> Well, Taylor, you've been cutting
me off this whole time, which is not helpful. >> Okay,
respectfully,
I all I am saying is that when you're writing an article, we
do our best to be accurate. Now, if Olivia Juliana is not
>> Hutch will 100% say she called him a white nationalist.
No, she's saying, yeah, obviously Sorry. What she's trying to
say is
white nationalists
like press me on this because they don't have a substantive argument
against the >> On August 27th, you tweeted the 90 influencers
involved appear to be primarily centrist, pro-DNC.
>> Who have not spoken about Palestine
are pro-Israel.
Those are your words.
>> But you just said a moment ago you're kind of distancing
yourself from that >> No, I >> Oh, you said that.
>> What are you talking about? You >> What Toypilled
just confronted you with and you said, "Well, I can let people
walk away with that." But those are your
>> They're centrist like again if Olivia Julianna is not
a centrist and that is factually wrong and these people are not
centrist and this is factually wrong. >> You said you were
distancing. Hold on. Hold on. Do we roll it back? >> If
you're saying that the centrist
>> Oh my god. >> uh was not something that you picked,
is that your way of saying that you're kind of distancing yourself
from that >> I don't I would I would I would have until
this conversation called Olivia Julianna a centrist because she's
a Democrat and a right >> So no. No, I'm not distancing
myself from that language. Hotch, you are an idiot. You didn't
listen to her response cuz you never listen to the responses
of anybody you talk to. You always ignore the people you talk
to. You never listen to what they say and that's why you look
like an idiot again back here where you say, "Well, so it sounded
like you were distancing yourself from that." No, you just made
that up. You just made that up in your head. >> Toypilled
just confronted you with and you said, "Well, I can let people
walk away with that." But those are your
>> They're centrist like again if Olivia Julianna is not
a centrist and that is factually wrong and these people are not
centrist and this is factually wrong. That that that these content
creators that are making content with Chuck Schumer, that are
making content with Hakeem Jeffries, if they are not if I was
wrong if if this article is wrong and it's factually wrong, then
I highly encourage them to ask for a correction. But no one has
asked for a >> step by steps. >> saying that it's
that they are not centrist. No one. >> Let's just do it
step by step. Hutch, is it your contention that it's inaccurate
to call Olivia Juliana a centrist? >> I do believe that,
yes. And I think that >> In virtue of what?
>> Well, I don't know why you're playing >> separating
from Taylor. >> He's trying to help you make an actual
argument, you
invalid. He's trying to help you not sound stupid. Take the life
raft, man. Take the He's throwing you out like a life saver.
You You've fallen off the boat. You're The boat is slowly sailing
away from you. You're in the middle of the ocean, and he's trying
to throw you a life preserver. He's trying to throw you that
little ring that's tied to the rope, and you're like sitting
there you're like, "Peace go. I think it's a little embarrassing
you think I need this, okay?" While we slowly sail further and
further away from you, Hutch. Please, just take the help. >> So,
you're using that word. It's a >> Separate No, wait. No,
hang on. So, >> I appreciate that intent, though. >> So,
you can make a you can make a critique of an article based on
its accuracy or based on whether there's some bad motive. >> I'm
trying to get to a larger
>> I know, but I'm >> Let's do it step by step, right?
>> I'm trying to, but you're jumping >> Is it inaccurate?
And so, and if it's inaccurate, why is it inaccurate?
>> It's inaccurate because her policy priorities do not
line up with what any reasonable person would assert to be
>> So, when So, I pull is like, "Hey, Hutch, it seems like
you're just trying to argue over this. I'm going to move it forward."
Hutch is like, "Oh, stop interrupting me." And now, Peacego's
like, "Can we move it forward and like we shouldn't be doing
this? We We should Here's like You have some deeper critique."
And Hutch says he has some deeper critique, and he's like, "So,
no reasonable person would see this woman as a centrist."
>> Okay. Another Another part of your reporting referred
to an older article that you wrote, I think a few months before
this course one, and you had described a 2024 situation where
the Biden administration was your quote was snubbing creators
who had lightly criticized Biden. Is Do you remember saying that?
>> I think you're talking about my Washington Post article
when I wrote
the Biden administration effectively blacklisting content creators.
>> Right. Yeah. >> and in your in your Wired article
about
you described that as the the the Biden you said in 2024 President
Joe Biden's White House snubbed several prominent content creators
after they lightly criticized the administration over its policies
on climate change, COVID, Gaza, and the TikTok ban. >> Yes.
Yeah, they did. Yeah.
>> My issue with that is the word lightly because I actually
>> It's another tone police. It's tone policing again.
It's literally just tone policing again. There's no way they
finally start to move a little bit and he's like Now my contention
is with this adjective you used. I think you used the wrong adjective
here and that's what I want to talk about today. Bro, I
Oh my god. Hutch, just be thankful I'm streaming on Twitch right
now, okay? I'd be saying horrifying, terrible,
inhuman things right now if I were not on Twitch, okay? I'd be
in play. >> And I looked up the creators that you mentioned
in that article. One of them was Aiden Kohn Murphy. He was tweeting
that Biden created a man a man-made famine, was ignoring the
law to enable
>> all of that. He was blacklisted for the climate stuff.
>> Well, you mentioned him and so like I when you say lightly
>> Wait, but at that point he had only lightly criticized.
So Biden the Biden >> that's not true. I went through his
tweets and I found tweets in 2024 if you >> talking about
you're talking about Aiden Kohn Murphy who is the co-founder
of TikTok for Biden, just to be clear. The co-founder of TikTok
for Biden. So Aiden ended up being very critical of Joe Biden.
However, he That a 2020 effort. No, that was well into 2022.
That was Tik Tok for Biden. >> Yeah, he exactly he Gen
Z for change was but in 2024 but in 2024 Taylor he was he was
directly accusing Biden of being complicit in genocide. >> But
we're not talking about that we're not we're he's booking speaking
by the way as a as a member of Gen Z for change he's talking
about the evolution of Tik Tok for Biden through Gen Z for change
and part of the reason why Tik Tok for Biden became Gen Z for
change and part of the reason why there was this whole evolution
is because Biden's
>> Okay, so once again, we're witnessing Hutch not
listen when another person is talking.
Why can't Hutch just listen and integrate the things other people
say into how he thinks about things? It's dude, as soon as she
goes, you have to understand this. You have to be able to to
hear this and realize you're going in a bad direction.
So you're saying hey, this guy was canceled and it wasn't just
like criticism. He accused Biden of manufacturing a famine. And
she goes oh, but he was actually blacklisted before that before
he started criticizing Biden on the genocide and you just keep
talking about 2024 2024 genocide Israel.
She's already said it was before that he was blacklisted. So
you either need to go to some point before that or some different
point to actually try to make something happen here, but you
just keep repeating the same thing that you would already plan
to say. You're clearly reading something and not paying
And everybody else can see it. I know that it's hard for you.
I know that this is difficult, but my God man, could you please
listen to other people when they talk? I I say that AS SOMEBODY
WHO'S KIND OF infamous for not listening the best sometimes,
but holy I do a lot better than this guy. >> whoever was
in charge of of sort of digital press there was blacklisting
creators that were even just lightly critical and I'm not saying
that Aiden I'm not
maybe Aiden eventually was not, but I will tell you that there
was also Elise Joshi. She made similar accusations. She She accused
the Biden administration of >> of being genocidal, right?
No, no, no, but Elise wasn't banned for any of that. It was It
was the climate stuff. It was This was the climate stuff and
for COVID. So, this is all back in No, this is all back in in
2022,
2023, even 2021 when Biden started to to say, "Hey, COVID is
over. Everybody get back to work." A lot of disability justice
activists, a lot of climate activists were like lately being
like, "Hey, well, what about this? What about these that you
made, right?" Khalil Green
Hutch is like blown out completely. Hutch is totally blown out.
Everything he Everything he wrote down is is like you could throw
it away. You go, "Oh, my bad." But he actually can identify this,
He He can't identify that the things he wrote down are no longer
valid, that he like he can't continue down the same
And it's lost on him. So, he's just humiliating himself again.
Trust me.
Do we think it's lost on Pisco? Pisco looks like he's not having
a great time. I dare I say it might not even be lost on But this
point, okay? He might realize it, too.
Like people realize that Hutch is not making good points. You
are not doing well right now. And unfortunately, if they say
anything or try to move it forward, you're going to cry that
everybody's being mean to you and call for daddy. So, I guess
they're just going to let you ruin the show for as long as you
want. >> Okay, I want You know, listen, I don't I don't
want to bombard you. Let me make one more kind of like have if
you don't
>> I don't want to bombard you. What has this been, like
40 minutes of just you trying to get her to admit that she's
Like 40 straight minutes. I don't want to bombard you. Just one
more quick >> If you're okay, I'd like to ask you just
one more question regarding the piece and then we can kind of
get to the overall point and just finish it. >> SHE'S DOING
IT AGAIN.
SHE'S ROLLING HER EYES AGAIN.
OH, Hutch is blown out. SHE GOT WAY BETTER faces than you, Hutch.
She's way funnier than you, Hutch. Blown the [__]
out. But, totally blown the [__] out. Hold on, let
me find You guys remember this? This is from the I recognize
this face. I've seen this face before. Hold on.
>> You remember this? That's That's the feeling, okay?
That's the feeling. >> I mean, never ask me or Pisco or
Guy or >> Okay, let's hear it. Let's hear it. >> And
she By the way, she like answered
She wrapped it all up. It's like all of the cur- the stuff you're
talking about. That was after they got blacklisted.
Just didn't really engage with it. Just moved on. >> I
guess. >> of your reporting that I think is the weakest,
the most vulnerable to attack, is your characterization of the
contract language. Specifically, when you talked about the contract
required Course creators to funnel booking appearances through
Course. They had to get its >> Now, Pisco's nodding as
if this is a good criticism. Pisco's totally wrong on >> It's
authorization
before they
What what What was it? Put up content or set up interviews, this
kind of a thing? >> No, they had to go They had to funnel
They had to leverage the Course newsroom when they were making
But, when they were booking appearances. >> In the contract,
that's what it said.
>> But, that's not But, that Well, we'll get to that in
a minute. >> Yeah, and I Look, like certain people had
certain aspects of the contract enforced against them. Certain
people didn't have aspects of the contract enforced against them.
And again, >> creators that were told that they had to
funnel all their bookings through
>> Every creator because they were given a contract that
says they have to do that,
So, every creator was told that? By the contract. >> Um
we did speak to a creator who didn't sign the contract because
of that. >> that's not what I asked. >> See, this
is
This is what you get used to having to do in like these sorts
of spaces is basically cuz I used to have be very much like um
like what Taylor's doing. Where like somebody would ask me something
and I never think of like why they're asking or what they're
trying to drive at. I would just be like, "Oh, I know the answer
to that. I'll answer it, right?" You should never ever ever
let yourself just be driven that direction. What you should say
here is, "No, they were they were all given a contract that says
that? That's what told them that."
He's trying to turn it into something else, but it's totally
moronic to think like, "Oh, well, they if they asked and then
they were told." No, they were given a contract. That's them
being told. You can say you didn't ask about the contract, but
that is the only relevant thing and that's the only thing they
reported on. They didn't say, "Oh, all these creators actually
got, you know, some creator got kicked out because they refused
to do this or some creator got kicked out because they booked
something on their own." They didn't say that. They just said
what the contract says. >> were told that. Yes, they were
told that. Yes, they were told that. >> Not that they were
told. I'm I'm asking you, did you actually get a single example
from any creator who actually had to funnel booking through Chorus?
>> Well, yeah, we spoke to a lot of creators that funneled
booking. >> That actually had to.
What do you call it when you're told to by the people paying
you? What do you do? What do you call it when your employer says,
"Hey, go sweep up that
Oh, you like I work here and you are employing me and that's
a part of my job description. So, I'm going to go do the thing
that's a part of my job description? Yeah, I'm being told to
do >> through Chorus. >> No, no, no. >> Wait,
[laughter] hang on. I'm I'm asking you, did you talk to anyone
that [snorts] told you that all of the bookings that they did
had to go through >> We spoke to a creator who was told
that all of the bookings that they had to do were Sorry, if they
wanted to do bookings, it would have to be filtered through Chorus
and so he chose not to take that Just let me finish. >> There's
no way. What are we What are we missing on here? What am I trying
I feel like Hutch is trying to say like basically did somebody
go outside of this and then get like reprimanded for it? So,
if you're told you have to start work at 9:00 a.m. and it's like,
"Well, did you talk to anybody who came in at like 10:00 a.m.
regularly and did they actually get in trouble?"
Well, no, the employer told them 9:00 a.m. So, they showed up
at 9:00 a.m. Actually, they couldn't go to work at 9:00 a.m.
So, they quit that job. But, did anybody actually get punished
for not showing up at 9:00 a.m.? No, cuz nobody tried to do that.
Cuz nobody does that. >> I I think that's what he's trying
to go for, and it's moronic.
>> I'm asking you, did you talk to anyone that told [snorts]
you that all of the bookings that they did had to go through
>> We spoke to a creator who was told that all of the bookings
that they had to do were Sorry, if they wanted to do bookings,
it would have to be filtered through Chorus. And so, he chose
not to take that Just Why don't you let me finish? Why don't
you let me finish? >> You're not answering the question.
>> I am answering your question. >> You're not. I'm
asking you a question.
>> It's so stupid. Why is nobody making fun of this person?
Why is This is supposed to be This is like
Is liberalism totally dead? Is Why is nobody saying, "Hey, Hutch,
you understand you're saying something stupid." Pisco?
Irai? Irai, are you playing Tetris? What the are you even doing?
Are you listening to conversation?
What is this guy doing? WHAT ARE YOU
What is your purpose here? What exactly would you say you do
here, buddy? Doesn't look like you're really doing anything,
man. Like this is Like yeah, okay. I I wasn't going to go in
on Pisco, but Pisco has to understand that this is horrible discourse.
This is like not a good conversation.
And that Hutch is asking you for something stupid. And the only
reason you would ever frame something this way is because you
are the person who is biased, and you're trying to use a biased
frame to make it look like Taylor did something wrong, but she
didn't, and we all can see that she didn't. Again, 9:00 a.m.
start time example, that's that's the hypothetical. That's putting
it in a different
But, these guys are pretending that like, "Oh, well, um actually,
I talked to somebody who showed up at 10:00 a.m. every day, and
they didn't get punished. So, that means that they they didn't
have to show up at 9:00 a.m."
Oh, it doesn't. >> In practice, did you have a single example
of a creator >> who told you that Course in Practice told
them they had to funnel everything >> In practice, this
is a stupid differentiation.
This is a stupid differentiation. These people are supposed to
be like the party of working class people, by the way. Democrats.
They're Democrats. They're for the working class. You know, the
working class where we put something in a contract, and then
we hope you honor it, but it's actually illegal. It's not something
we can enforce. That's definitely pro-working class, right?
For sure. We're going to put something in a contract that we
can't enforce or we don't want to enforce even, but we're going
to hope that most people will like not really question and just
do it. And yeah, we're pro-working class, actually. Very cool.
>> to Course.
>> Can you What you just described is not that. So, >> Well,
I'm trying to give you additional context, but >> I just
spent 12 hours preparing for
>> You don't want to. [laughter] >> No, I do, but
I You're not answering my >> answered your question. Yes.
>> I don't think you are. >> Okay. Can Can you repeat
it, Taylor, just just in case? >> You're kind of just describing
the stream here. You're kind of just describing the way the stream
works most of the time, actually. I Yes, that's the stick. Yes.
Realistically, if I was going to like calm down and just give
a totally calm answer, I think this looks really bad for everybody
involved, except Taylor. I think that Hutch is particularly
is particularly motivated and performing poorly. He's particularly
motivated to try to prove Taylor wrong on something, and it's
leading to him just making assertions and and not He can't follow
up any of his assertions like after he makes them. So, he's like,
"Oh, these people It wasn't soft criticism that got these people
kicked out." And she explains it, and he can't deal with that,
right? >> We spoke to creator We spoke to a creator that
did that was told when he pushed back on the contract before
the contract was signed. He was like, "Hey, I kind of want to
sign this contract. I kind of wanted this program, but there's
this clause that says I have to use the Course Newsroom. Do I
really have to use the Course Newsroom for booking?" He was told
through his agent, "Yes, you do have to use the Course Newsroom
for booking. Other people, when they took part in the program,
when they said, "Oh yeah, I'm going to book this thing." they
were told, "You have to use the Corus Newsroom for that." And
they did ultimately use the Corus Newsroom. Other people used
the Corus Newsroom and didn't have did never questioned it. They
didn't They was in the contract and it would have never occurred
to them to even question what was in the contract because they
signed a contract saying this, so they didn't challenge it. Um
when we they were asked for comment on this, Corus didn't deny
it. And that's That's the truth of that's all the information
>> Categorically blown out. There's everything everything
you needed to know. There it all is.
>> Uh it's untrue, but that doesn't That's not the same
as verifying >> No, they didn't deny it. >> Well,
that's not the same as verifying that the letter of the contract
was actually being enforced. And that's the big issue here.
>> No, that's not the big issue, idiot. Oh my god. Who?
How do you
purport to be for working class people
and then say that employers putting like
contract parameters into their employment contracts
that is a good practice that there's nothing wrong with that
that that's not like the major issue.
Like some some unethical or unproductive contract clause or just
super employer favored contract clause. Right? That's unenforceable
that they technically have no intention to enforce because it's
either legally dubious or ethically dubious and they put it in
there hoping you'll do it. Right? Like if I write, um actually
I'm going to I'm going to write this contract for talent and
actually you have to give me a once a day. That's my That's my
employment contract, okay? And then I basically never ever tell
the person they have to do it, but they come in and do the thing.
Okay, have I done something
I can't force them to do that. It's It's illegal. I cannot force
them to do that, okay? Yes, it's a tech tone special,
But then they start doing it. Have I done something wrong?
Can I say, "Well, I never I never forced them to do that. I never
What What do you mean? What What actually matters is whether
or not I forced them to do that. What do you mean?" Well, technically,
you offered them the contract and the provision was in there,
and they need the money, so they took it and followed the provisions.
And you're going to claim that because you didn't tell them to
do it or that like they basically said, "I don't want to do this."
And you're like, "No, you have to do this."
That's the only way it could be wrong?
I don't think so. I don't think that's the way it works. >> They
didn't They didn't deny it, and yeah, they didn't deny it. >> But
but that's still your job as a journalist to verify that it's
something that's important. >> it with the content creators
who said on the record that this happened, and that's why it's
in the story. >> I don't think you demonstrated that in
the story. You didn't demonstrate that you spoke to them. >> saying
that he chose not to sign the contract over this. >> That's
not the same thing though. I I feel like you're being quite a
bit >> Yeah, so to be clear, like Taylor, there's a difference
between a creator understood this contract to be I can't do anything
unless I go through the >> They were not allowed That is
what the contract says. That's what the contract
It's not even debatable that's what the contract says. And the
response you have to that is, "Well, this one Gen Z girl on TikTok
said that she booked an interview with somebody, and she didn't
run it through them, and that disproves everything you No, it
doesn't.
No, it doesn't. >> How All evidence that we have shows
that that's how it was.
>> Did some people that maybe not have the contract enforced
against them? >> Sure, I I'm willing I'm I'm sure because
clearly they were only enforcing certain parts of the contract.
>> Taylor doesn't understand that these guys are all Destiny
fans. They came up watching Destiny's streams. And they need
Listen, Taylor, if you cannot force this into some overly
analogy like the contract, they will never understand. >> I
Where What is your evidence for that, by the way? >> Speaking
to the content creators.
>> But that nothing about that was in your article that
gave me the sense that they were giving preferential treatment
and
here and there. That was not in your >> Well, literally,
I mean, you can see in the article certain people Why Why do
you think this article exists? Because the content creators were
frustrated. They wanted to speak out about things. They felt
like they weren't able to speak out. That's why That's part of
why they spoke. >> Well, I You know, the other thing was
like the takedown clause. Like that sounds very restrictive,
right? The way that you >> I can
What is it about Taylor Lorenz that breaks people's brains? That
these people can't just admit that the article is good and they
lost and they probably just need to move on. That the response
was so bad that there is no way to like rehab this. They just
keep walking into this buzzsaw. This like
middle-aged white woman buzzsaw every single time. Every single
time they walk into it and she's just like, "Ha ha. I I know
I'll try to explain to you how journalism works, okay? I'll just
Oh my god, I get this a lot and sometimes people just don't know
how journalism works, okay?" And like they just keep walking
into the the valley girl buzzsaw every time. Again and again
and again, >> Your your your your article describes that
language as that, you know, Chorus reserved the right to like
strike down any content. >> directly from the contract,
yeah. >> I understand.
The problem here, Taylor, is with all three of these things,
the final >> Do you understand though? Do you understand?
Are you sure you understand? >> express authorization,
takedown clauses. Would this not be standard language in a contract
for a 501c4? >> I've seen a lot of these contracts. >> Yep,
it would. It would. I said that when I looked into all this stuff.
Glad Hutch finally figured it out a year and a half later or
however long it's been. A year later? Probably 9 months later,
right? August 2024? 2025? Maybe? >> Facts, I just wrote
another story for Wired on another dark money influencer program
and none of this language has been in the other contracts that
I've seen that are for similar programs.
>> Okay, but but you understand that like obviously you
know like a 501c4 they have to be in compliance with like the
law and to protect their status they can't they can't have a
a certain above a certain threshold of their operational kind
of structure and and and and funds and stuff going towards things
like campaigns and elections and things like that. So in context
in that context >> I'm telling you I I write about that
I write about
>> Could you could you not read this language as a company
that is trying to protect itself the status and the creators
themselves from violating the >> Well, the creators themselves
often didn't agree with what was in the contract and were frustrated
that they couldn't speak out for instance
>> This is the only good point I've heard from Hutch this
entire time. He's spoken for basically an hour now, maybe 40
minutes. This is the first good point I've heard him make. Right?
Is that probably the contract and this is what I said when I
originally looked at this is probably the contract is standard
for a 501c4 because they can only put so much money into certain
things. They can only spend so much money like interviewing candidates
or overtly supporting any party. And so it's almost certainly
actually a
a requirement in terms of what is it campaign finance law that
they do this.
I don't I while that is true
I don't think it makes it okay to make it so that they can't
like disclose things. I don't think man
And again they could have cleared that up with a comment, right?
All you have to do is say the the exact I just gave that in order
to comply with campaign finance law we have to make sure we have
some control over this and so while we have no interest in enforcing
it like arbitrarily we will have to enforce it sometimes to make
sure we stay within the bounds of the law. We're not telling
content creators what to do, but if if through happenstance our
content creators end up interviewing like the same candidate
or working in a district too much, we will have to shut that
down because we can't let that happen over and over again. We're
funding these people and in order to give them the freedom they
want there are some restrictions that will come with it. It's
not really restrictions on the content. It's like, "Oh, if through
happenstance you guys happen to conflict in a way where we're
putting way too much money into one race, one candidate, I we
will have to pause you guys on
That's a downside of the way we're setting this up, but the upside
is we can take in a bunch of money.
If they just responded with something like that, that makes them
look way better. BUT INSTEAD, WHAT BRYAN Tyler Cohen responded
with was, "Well, I think Candace Owens said something nice about
Taylor Lorenz once." That was the response. So, I I know Taylor's
probably, you know, in defensive mode. She's not going to be
aggressive about this, but she should be. She should She should
say, "Well, if they just told us that if they if they come to
us and said something like that, we would totally published it,
and we could have we would have made that a part of the article."
But they didn't say that. They actually just attacked us for
publishing the
>> Anyway, they disclosed that they were in the program.
There's nothing to do with the law. Well, that's in the contract,
and that's exactly what we're talking about here, right? >> not
though. I'm talking about the the funneling, Express authorization,
take down clauses. All of these can be explained by a 501c4.
>> Oh, the 501c4 thing is not responsible for the funneling.
Or I guess maybe maybe you could say it's responsible, but then
but then you are haha.
If it's if that's required for a 501c4, which I would argue it
is, then they do have to funnel all their stuff through Chorus,
don't they?
Right? You can you argue both sides of that? Can you argue that
they don't need to funnel all of their contacts, all of their
meetings, all of their bookings through Chorus, but also that
it's required filing or required oversight for a 501c4 so they
don't violate campaign finance law?
It seems like it's actually critical that they do funnel all
of their bookings through Chorus because it allows them to prevent
themselves from violating campaign finance law. No?
So, then then the whole thing over funnel everything you've argued
over funnel is totally moot, and they obviously were being told
that they have to force everything through Chorus. >> Try
to be compliant with the law. No, because I mean I just wrote
about another 501 C4 that literally just ran another dark money
campaign in in some cases with approached some of the same exact
course influencers and none of this was in that contract. So
>> But their lack of potentially standard 5013C things
is not or four is not evidence that this is not standard. >> saying
it's not standard. You guys are saying it's standard. I'm saying
I've never I have not seen it in other contracts. That doesn't
mean that it doesn't exist in some contracts. >> are you
are you claiming it's standard? You're not claiming it's standard,
are
>> Pisco just caught the same thing I did. I feel like
I'm almost positive that Pisco just caught the same thing I did
cuz if you're going to argue it's standard, then you are arguing
that the funnel thing is absolutely something they were required
to do. I feel like Pisco just picked that up immediately.
My brother Pisco, please tell me you picked that up, too. >> Based
on what I looked into, this language would be consistent with
a 501C4 that is protected >> Is it your claim that it's
standard or >> Hang tight, Pisco. We can talk in a second.
So, Taylor
>> I just I dude, I Again, ignorance plus arrogance, whole
that does a number on me so fast so fast. Ignorance plus arrogance
makes me lose my
>> Hey, little bro. How about you walk Hey, step off, little
bro. I ain't talking to you, little bro. >> want to answer
you conveniently. >> creator if a creator for example uploaded
a video to their channel where they were endorsing a particular
candidate and the channel this video was framed as >> By
the way, I will just say if Pisco did notice that and he brings
it up later, like I'm just going to say people think sometimes
I'm like just looking to take Pisco's side in things when I am
covering stuff. No, I just I'm just capable of evaluating the
world. I'm just capable of seeing things. So, I think he noticed
the same thing I did that you basically you're going to argue
that the funnel thing wasn't required, but also that it was boilerplate
like standard for a 501C4. You can't do both of those arguments
at the same time. >> Something that came from Course. Could
that uh uh could that threaten Course's nonprofit status?
>> I think you'll have to look into the details of sort
of like how that creator was using it. >> answer is yes.
It could it could possibly threaten their status. So, if they
had a if they had a clause in their contract that they could
take down content, would it not be a better like a good faith
interpretation that they could very easily be trying to protect
>> seen a C4 put this stuff in a contract
there is something to be said there, okay? The reason this needs
to go into a C4 in this case, and it might not be in other cases,
is because usually the C4s are operated in good faith and they're
not trying to So, what Course is trying to do is they are trying
to partisanly support Democrats.
They're absolutely that is the the point of Course, right? So,
the 501c4s they're not they're supposed to be nonpartisan based
on issues. This 501c4 is a obviously an incredibly
pointedly supporting Democrats, right?
And so, the reason they put that in is so that they can just
barely dodge campaign finance law in a way other 501c4s shouldn't
have to. Did Hutch ask ChatGPT and it told him it was standard
language? No, no, no, no, no. This is I mean, I wouldn't be shocked
like Hutch might as well have watched my coverage of this like
the day after the article released cuz this is the article I
was making or sorry, this is the argument I was making. Was I
think they had to put this language in to protect themselves
to make sure they were not hitting 501c4 like problems
because you're supposed to be nonpartisan when you're a 501c4.
If you are again campaigning on behalf of Democrats or on behalf
of a specific Democratic candidate, you're not supposed to do
that. And so, they need to mark or they need to track who they're
paying and who they're interviewing because if they're ever paying
people to do these interviews and they overlap too much, they
could be they could lose their 501c4 status. Right? And so, it
is in some ways standard for a for an organization that wanted
to do partisan electioneering
but through a 501c4 to add this language. But probably most 501c4s
wouldn't because they're not partisan in
Anyway, we keep going. >> We'll get to that after after
this part. >> But maybe they do you know, maybe they do.
But like I said, I have reported on on campaigns and I haven't
seen it there before. I haven't you know, for instance, the Build
American AI thing I just wrote about, they don't have Build American
AI newsroom that you have to use you know, like I haven't seen
this sort of language >> it's possible. Would you can see
that it's possible that this language was specifically crafted
to make sure that they were compliant with the law? >> Until
they comment on the record and
>> That's that's by the way
that's what I said and that's what I said they should respond
with while they still had plenty of time to respond on the article.
Like I I read that article the day it came out. That was what
I said. I said they should respond. They should say something
along the lines of we had to do this. We we are not like looking
to control the creators. It's everything I said before. I already
gave this response. But that's what they could have responded
with and so much of the heat just goes away. So much of it.
But the problem is if they say the problem is I think they could
be you know, opening themselves up opening themselves up to some
kind of investigation. If they say, well, actually we're trying
to do a little
You know what I'm saying? Like if they say, well, we're trying
to make sure that you guys even though you're kind of partisan
and going one direction, we're trying to make sure you guys don't
run a foul of a foul of campaign finance law. It's like, okay,
but why did you have to do that? Right? Yeah.
Yeah, I don't >> in their stuff. Speaking behind it, I
mean you you we have no idea what their motivations were for
>> Well, well, but Taylor, I mean like let's be realistic
here. Like obviously there are things that these people are restricted
by. They cannot appear partisan in certain aspects. And so >> that
doesn't trickle down to the but that doesn't trickle down to
the creator. And I'm actually not confident at all in your reading
of that. I would really want to talk to a lawyer and I'd want
to talk to somebody that works on these contracts and say, hey,
I've reported on lots of these contracts. Why is it only in this
contract and not others? Why did they structure it this way and
>> If only there was a lawyer on the panel, man. If only
Could you imagine if there was a lawyer on the panel? >> not in
other ways. I I'm not saying >> Were you Were you made
aware of any actual instance where Corus um requested to take
down content from any creator? >> No, we didn't find any
enforcement action on that. >> Were you Were you made aware
of of of any creator that that had to get express authorization
before like setting up a uh interview with a politician? >> We
did talk to creators that were told they had to use the Corus
news. >> No, no, but you keep doing this.
man, I don't know.
I feel like I need something. I It's just so It's so stupid.
>> it's cool. I signed the contract. >> I but listen,
all I can tell you is what my reporting says and I know you guys
want more. All I can tell you is what my reporting says and what
I found and who who we spoke to. I'm sorry, I'm not going to
keep going around in circles. It is so pointless. None of this
is relevant. You don't seem to have this issue with any other
article that I've written about this stuff. It's crazy. It's
just this article >> article of yours that I'm familiar
with. I I did a lot of research and a lot of >> know like
Okay, okay. All right, I'm sorry that like just like I I'm trying
to explain what my reporting says and what I found. >> That's
fine. I don't want I don't want to press you further. >> I just
want to say that >> I don't know why Soy Pill's laughing.
This is embarrassing content. You normally like moderate or manage
this. I don't know why you're laughing right now. Why are you
laughing? Why do you find this so funny? Your friend is humiliating
themselves. They're a complete [__] Why are you just
laughing at it? Why aren't you saying like, "Hey, why don't we
move on? Hey, why don't we do this?" Why don't you do something?
>> Like I I'm trying to explain >> at this guy be
You're like laughing as he
lights himself on fire. >> Look, I don't want I don't want
to press you further. >> That's fine. I don't want I don't
want to press you further. I just want to say >> You know,
I I do think that you have >> No, I Here's the thing. I
don't think Soy Pill wants Hutch to humiliate himself and make
their show look stupid. I don't think Soy Pill wants that. I
hope he doesn't want that. I have no idea. It's like funny for
me that Hutch is humiliating himself, right? I assume for everybody
else on here, they actually want this show to go somewhere and
be something. So, like if I
It's like watching your business partner like physically assault
a customer who you rely on for income and you're just like laughing.
Like, probably you should do something. Right? You're You're
at some business. You run like a You run like a wall-climbing
business, okay? You're You're like a a climbing club, and you're
watching your your business partner assault a customer. It's
just like you're laughing instead of doing something. Like, you're
you're literally causing massive problems for your business right
now. This guy's [__] your business. How do we How
do we do something about that? We should do something about that.
It's going badly. Can we do something about that? >> You
had an agenda with this article. I do think that you had opinions
that you put in the article. >> You can join the many the
the the people on the >> I I think the narrative that you
were pressing was that the big bad corrupt establishment was
paying Democratic shills and suppressing leftist voices. I think
that >> Leftist voices? Where's the leftist voices in that?
Where does it say leftist What What do you Where are you even
getting that from, Hudge?
>> Okay. Okay, Taylor.
There's like a little hint of that. I don't think it's enough
of a hint that you like have to say it's you know, disingenuous.
I don't think it's the main thrust of the article, but there's
like a little hint of like, "Well, you know, you kind of get
some pro-Israel people, and there's not really a lot of Gaza
voices, and maybe you flood the zone with with people who won't
talk about the genocide." There's a little bit of it. There's
a little bit of it, and certainly there is a lot of it in the
interviews post-article.
>> People connected to the article >> but not being
radically left is not the same thing as being centrist, Taylor.
>> Right. I understand that, but I'm saying
>> Okay. What What label to make you happy so I don't trigger
you with the wrong word? What >> Something reasonable.
>> No, no. Okay. [laughter] >> Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, >> What? What?
What? Is this the Is it No. What?
>> Okay. What What label to make you happy so I don't trigger
you with the wrong word? What >> Something reasonable.
>> No, no. Okay. >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
>> Ryan Tyler Cohen is literally a centrist to so many
people, Hudge. Yes. Yes, lots of people would say that would
would call him a centrist. I don't think Bro, he is a center-left
Democrat. He is a center-left Democrat. That's just objectively
true. You're going to say he's a progressive? I think within
even Dude, even the Dem voter base, he's got to be in like the
middle of the Dem voter base.
What are we talking about, man? >> Hutch, Hutch, Hutch,
the the Democratic Party is a center-left party, is that >> Is
Brian Tyler Cohen a centrist? >> Wait, wait, Hutch, can
you answer one question? Answer one question. >> You answer
mine. >> Answer one question. Is the Democratic Party center-left?
>> Is Brian Tyler Cohen a centrist? >> Wait, is Brian
Tyler Cohen a centrist? >> I'm center-left. You're center-left.
We're all Pisco's question. >> Okay. Hutch, what is the
right word >> Hutch, Hutch, wait, wait, wait, wait, answer
the question. Hutch, is the Democratic Party Hutch, Hutch, Hutch.
>> Yeah, I think this is another good argument you can
make. I don't know if she's going to try to go this way,
another easy way to go with this is, okay, we called her a a
progressive. What changes about the article, Hutch?
We called her We called her a progressive now? What changes?
Why is talking over Pisco
because sees that Pisco's going to get enraged here with Hutch
being an [__] Hutch talked this entire time, and
now Hutch won't let anybody else get a word in. Hutch has not
let anyone else get a word in this entire show. Hour 35 or sorry,
since we picked it up, which is, I think, 40 minutes in. So,
we've watched for an hour now. Hutch has barely let anybody else
speak. Every time somebody else tries to speak, he yells about
people talking over him, okay? Sorry, knows that Pisco's going
to lose it pretty quick. And so, he's trying to keep the peace.
He's trying to go, "Hey, Hutch, Hutch, Hutch, answer Pisco's
question first." That's what I mean. >> All right, all
right, all right. >> I'm center-left. You're center-left.
We're all >> Answer Pisco's question. >> Okay. Hutch,
what is the right word >> Hutch, Hutch, wait, wait, wait,
wait, answer the question. Hutch, is the Democratic Party Hutch,
Hutch, Hutch. >> You were using a pejorative, and you know
that's what you were doing. >> That's different, Hutch.
Is Hutch, is the Democratic Party a center-left >> Yes,
broadly, yes. >> Okay. So, if what is So, if what is meant
by centrist, right? It's the stupidest [__] point.
If if what is all is meant by centrist is your alignment with
the Democratic Party, then this is all analytical, right? By
definition, being aligned with the Democratic Party on your own
view. >> Wait, when you think of the word >> On No,
you you would have to you would have to show you would have to
you would have to show in any given case that the use centrist
is more specific and that you're trying to call out something
and and maybe that is actually what Taylor is doing when she's
using centrist.
>> Did this guy not get enough speaking
Did he not get enough speaking time? Pisco is in the middle.
Pisco didn't even give any time any room for this guy to get
a word in and he just started talking over him. >> You
would have to you would have to show in any given case that the
use centrist is more specific and that you're trying to call
out something and and maybe that is actually what Taylor is doing
when she's using centrist.
>> Like he just he just cuts in. He's been talking the
entire show and he just cuts in.
[laughter] can't you can't be complaining about interruptions
and you're interrupting everyone all over the place, all right?
So >> Pisco has to be so nice all the time. Pisco has to
be so nice all the time.
>> In any given context, I think it's on you to just like
decipher what the intent is behind using the centrist label.
But the Democratic Party is a center-left party. >> She
was using the word centrist because the the people that she was
trying to appeal to with that article and I think it's obvious
who she who she was trying to appeal to. Use that >> the
progressive audience of Wired >> word in a disparaging
way similarly to how they use the word liberal in a disparaging
way. You know that Taylor >> Would you guys not describe
liberal? Do you guys not describe liberal? Do you not describe
yourself >> Liberal is appropriate. That's an appropriate
label. Liberals are center-left, correct? >> So let's call
them liberals. That will make you happy. >> You are a progressive
liberal, too, right? I mean I would like when I look at Brian
Tyler Cohen's like his like overall priorities and his >> Is
he liberal? >> I would call him a progressive liberal.
>> Okay, we will call him a progressive liberal. We will
use the word liberal and that will make you happy. >> Why
would she would have used that in the in the article instead
of saying centrist because you know that you're >> He said,
you know, people tried to save this guy. They're like, "Hey,
that's like a totally worthless conversation to have."
And they tried to save him from the beginning and he said, "Oh,
I have a bigger point to make." We're now an hour into him speaking
and trying to get to this point. He still hasn't got there. He's
still just being a total pedant about it. It's complete waste
of time. I They got to fix the dynamic of the show, man. Get
Josiah back on here. Josiah is not scared to let Hutch know when
he's being a [__] And he'll do it in that southern
way. He'll do it in that southern way where he's like, "Hey Hutch,
I think you're getting a little out over your skis here or something."
He'll say something like that, but at least he's not going to
be scared. Can we get somebody who's not scared on the show?
Anyone? Anybody who's not scared to tell this guy to stop. Hey,
chill.
>> Okay, you you're choosing to be a potted plant. That's
your choice, okay? Why are you Why Oh, do not get into the victimization
stuff. You are choosing to be a potted plant. You could easily
throw elbows. I thought you were going to get chippy, Pisco.
This was the opposite of chippy. This was you, yes, being a potted
plant. Thank you for acknowledging that.
So, like centrist Democrat to me, when you say centrist Democrat,
that means centrist within the Democratic Party. Because KORUS
is created to push the Democratic line, the thing they want to
push, the messaging they want out there. I would say, by definition,
they're obviously going to recruit mostly centrist Democrats,
and that you're not doing anything other than describing reality
accurately when you describe chorus that way.
I would just what I would love to know where the counterargument
is on that. >> Not Are they not liberal Democrats? Not
the liberal party, guys? >> We're not talking about the
term >> But you said But we're talking Okay, centrist >> that
term. You used that term. It wasn't your editor in your in your
tweet you said you used that >> Sure, I use the term centrist
all the time. I use the term centrist all the >> I'm saying
it in a derogatory way. Anyone can search your Twitter feed and
see when >> Oh, wait, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
wait. Oh, centrist also is not used in the article other than
describing Olivia
That's the only time it's used in the article. So, again, they're
using criticisms of her tweets to try to degrade the article,
but they are
Again, it is not even in the article. That is another thing from
a tweet
that's not in the article. So, when Piskopo says, "Well, is the
article accurate?" And they're like, "Well, it's something about
centrist."
Holy [__] Honestly, like I kind of want to I'm not
joking. Like I'm feeling like a an actual anger that I haven't
felt since like I was a teenager playing video games. Like I
I kind of want to I I I want to like break a keyboard or something.
Like I I have not felt this in forever. I haven't felt like this
much like genuine anger watching this. Like I actually kind of
want to just like break my keyboard in half. I won't do that
cuz it's an Apple It's like a It's a magic keyboard, okay? And
I love my my Apple keyboards, and they're very expensive. They're
like 200 bucks or something, 300 bucks. So, I would never do
that. But like I'm actually I'm feeling this emotion that I haven't
felt so long. Like so so so long. It's crazy.
Luckily, I'm an adult now. I know how to process my emotions.
I know how to control them a little bit, okay? So, I'm not going
to do anything. But I'm just saying like I actually feel rage
watching this.
>> You can also say I use the term every who And you get
the search my Twitter feed for the for the term leftist. See
what I have to say about the term leftist on my Twitter feed
and see if I'm being really nice about it. >> after this.
I will. I'm curious >> go do it right away. You'll You'll
see >> that language for a particular reason, >> No,
I use language I am criticizing different different political
factions constantly and you'll see. Please search the word leftist
and see what I have to say about the leftist. Please search this
word Okay, I >> You're establishing a cast of heroes and
villains. That's what you're doing. >> Like they were you
know, Hasan himself has made this claim. I'm like >> Hasan
was not even remotely part of this >> But you mentioned
him. You mentioned him in this article. You mentioned him in
the old article. You mentioned him in this tweet. >> I
was talking about him being like the [__] Joe Rogan
of the left or >> No, but you're presenting the virtuous
alternative to the corrupt Democratic shills. That That's what
you're doing in this whole thing. >> think Hasan is taking
dark money. >> But you're you're not Are you rejecting
that that that's what you're doing? Like that is what you're
doing, right? Like you're saying you have these like radical
leftists and they're
>> That's not what she's doing in the article. That might
be what she's doing in commenting after the article. That like,
"Hey, we need a better, more moral solution to the Democratic
Party's ills." That might be what she's doing after the article.
That's not a >> party of the article. They're pure and
they're not corrupt. And then you have the corrupt pro-DNC pro-Israel
shills, >> Search my Please search my Twitter feed and
see what I've said about the leftist. I feel like I'm losing
my mind. >> searched your Twitter and I you have been on
him quite a bit too. >> I constantly criticize people all
over the political ideology. I very intentionally don't identify
with one political faction over the other or whatever. And again,
I know that that pisses everybody off in that political faction.
But what I'm saying is that if you think that this is some bad
faith like article that's meant to like valorize the left and
like criticize that that's just not what the article says. And
I understand that my comments >> Well, the article did
say that they're not allowed to disclose their relationship with
Course. >> Yes, that's what it says. >> Hold on.
Now, is Hutch So, I'm going to be pedantic cuz these people are
all being pedantic, okay? That's not what it
Okay, that's not what it says. What it says is, "According to
copies of the contract viewed by Wired, that creators signed
the influencers are not allowed not allowed to disclose." It
doesn't say they're not allowed to disclose. It doesn't say that's
a universal law that applies independent of all other factors,
okay? It says that the contract states states that. The contract
says that. All course would have to do to get a correction here
is to produce the contract and say, "No, no, no, it doesn't say
that. You're But they didn't do that.
And Wired felt comfortable enough to risk a defamation lawsuit
to publish
What's confusing?
So, this is once again where Hutch is doing the thing, okay?
Well, if I put something in a contract that says you have to
blow me every day, and I never ever like fire you on days you
don't blow me, then have I done anything wrong? Just because
I accepted it a couple times? Yes, Hutch. Yes, you basically
you in a quiet way pushed that agreement on to somebody who is
possibly vulnerable, needed money from you, and you accepted
it. You accepted they accepted, and although it is like although
it's technically someways consensual, it is you are using your
advantage, the money the money you're paying them, your position
of influence as their employer, to extract some benefit that
you're not actually like entitled to or ethically is like dubious
for you to even demand. That is that in and of itself the contract
provision itself is wrong. That's the argument. >> No,
it's not though. It's not. We know that's not true. >> Wait,
sorry. They aren't allowed to >> Why why is it untrue?
Wait, wait, >> No, wait wait, wait, wait, wait. Why do
you think it's described in the >> Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Why do you think it's described in >> So, I
understand Listen, I I have my issues I want to bring my issues
with the with uh >> Why do you think I'm saying that? >> I
will definitely I will I will >> 100% Matt Max, yes. That
It's just it's embarrassing. This is like a major That man, it
feels like a thing to say. But it's like a major blow to their
podcast. Like this is actually a professional step backwards.
Like
Oh, man. Like for all the people who complain about any getting
slot kind, I can't believe Hutch did this with his time. You
know what I'm saying?
Like it's not even it's not even from an empathetic place. It's
like from a virtue signaling place. He spent almost the entirety
of the podcast being totally pedantic about things that substantially
changed nothing.
It's actually wild. I will definitely address that. Did he He
didn't say steel man me, did he? I missed it.
Why why is it untrue?
Why do you think it's describing the
Steel man. Steel man me. How about you make an argument, man?
How about you make an argument? Just make your argument.
Steel man me. Steel man me. You haven't even laid out your argument
I understand that it feels easier to say like the you feel like
somebody's not listening to you. It'll be shocking to me that
Hutch feels like he's not listening to you so much.
Eventually you got to wonder like am I doing a bad job? No. If
you have to so often say steel man me man, steel man me, steel
man me, steel man me. Shouldn't you be like kind of looking inward
and going oh what am I doing? What am I Am I doing something
wrong? Nobody understands. So I understand I have my issue I
want to bring my issue with the with uh Wait wait wait wait wait.
I will definitely address that. I will I will definitely I will
definitely address I will I will definitely address that.
I will definitely By the way, Hutch lied. Hutch lied. And it
said they're not allowed to do this. When when the claim is the
contract states they're not allowed to do it. That's all they
say. They don't say oh nobody ever did this. They're saying the
contract stated they were not allowed to do this. That's what
the article says. So I I want to be clear. I have my own problems
with with the article that has to do actually with contractual
contractual language in the title but I mean at this point it's
been I didn't write the title. I didn't write the title. Don't
The contractual
the article Are you asking me or are you asking Taylor? I'm asking
Taylor. Is the Is the subheading wrong then? But okay but you
can ask him. so important that's so important that's the subheading
No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's
not, man. No, it's not. This is so worthless.
I just I and I hate to do this this argument this sort of the
reverse of what they're doing. But if this was a Republican group
that had been reported on the same way, would any of them go
like well but they didn't force you to do the things? Would These
are arguments that are born entirely out of their proximity to
the group of people running Kors. They're close to Brian Tyler
Cohen either directly or indirectly, hosted David Pakman, either
directly or indirectly, Luke Beasley, Adam Mahler. These people
all operate in the same circles and it is purely their proximity
to those creators that is making them shill for this organization
this hard. And it's shameful.
It is shameful to watch.
>> It's not actually wrong. >> Well, you just said
you don't you didn't write it. So, I mean >> Yeah, journalists
don't write their >> But you have influence on the byline
on the subheading, right? You can't request that Wait, hang on.
>> No, it's factually correct. Why would I do that? >> Hang
on. Journalists can't request that a subheading is changed?
>> I would I would never do that unless it was factually
wrong. It's not factually >> This is absolutely factually
wrong though. I mean, like in your in your subheading you say
that online influencers were paid up to $8,000 a month to push
the party line.
>> That's what it was made for. It was made to push the
party line. That is what their explicit goal was was it was created
as an organization to push the party line. They're being paid
$8,000 a month. I There you go. It's a fact though. Paid $8,000
a month to push the party line. Factually correct.
That's how the That's how the decks Sorry, the the the decks
in the the marketing decks push the describe course
>> Everybody, literally everybody who's reading this, you're
just trying to be pedantic over nothing cuz you're a [__]
I >> Like like claim >> Right, we're talking about
you saying that they were getting paid $8,000 to push the party
line and there's no >> The whole point of the program was
to fix the Democratic Party's messaging problem. That's the whole
point of the >> But the but you're saying paid X to do
Y. That's a consideration for some sort of thing that in the
other end of it.
>> In aggregate.
And if you don't like that, then guess what? It's a little ambiguous.
You could think, "Oh, I'm paying you $8,000 to say the things
I want you to say." You could think that, but then that is dispelled
entirely by the actual reporting. And so, guess what? Clickbait
titles, kind of the way the world works. It is at best when it's
when it's put together in aggregate, it is to push the party
line that these people are being paid. And realistically, it's
like, "Okay, well, in an individual sense, maybe. Maybe.
>> I did have a question about that, but I wanted to address
what was just said about the characterization regarding the disclosure.
The article states that the contract the language of the contract
forbids disclosure. And I don't have any reason to believe that's
untrue.
Yeah, there were there were at What particular quote are you
are you pointing to here? >> See, like, Hutch is just benefiting,
and this is what happened with Destiny 2, that like they can
kind of make it look like they're correct to dumb people because
they do the the specific way of talking, the the debate language,
he does the eye rolls when she talks, right? He's doing all of
this other performance to make it seem like she's dumb and she's
bad and she's wrong. And so he could kind of do that, but as
soon as anybody who's familiar with any of those games steps
in and goes, wait,
I she didn't lie. It's it's like just functionally correct with
the contract language. Like the contract language described is
described correctly.
In fact, Hutch would argue that. You were arguing that a little
while ago. So what what was this whole thing that you think it's
a lie? >> Do you have the quote in front of you? I don't
have it in front of me, but I know it's it's characterized in
the >> the contract viewed by Wired that creators signed.
The influencers are not allowed to disclose their relationship
with Corsair or the >> That is accurate, [__]
When you just say, well, it says you they were forced to not
disclose, that's not what the reporting was.
>> But he actually can't tell the difference between the
contract stipulation and basically somebody sitting there with
a hammer waiting to hit bash people in the head who don't follow
the contract. Like he he thinks these things are the same thing.
And they're not. They're just not. And all you'd have to do is
be employed once in a regular job ever to know that. >> But
that's not true. Are you disputing the accuracy of that? What
what why why is it why do you think it's untrue? Because there's
two different things going on here. There's a qualifier like
according to the contract, but then she's making a claim. The
influencers are not allowed to disclose >> Dude, are you
serious?
Copies of the contract viewed by Wired that creators signed,
the influencers are not allowed to This is not separate. This
is all one sentence, Hutch. What do you mean that it's making
a claim? You dumb
I HE'S ACTUALLY ILLITERATE. I I WAS JOKING EARLIER. I didn't
know that this came up. He's actually illiterate.
He's actually
truly illiterate. That's insane. >> It's close to the relation
>> Yes, under the contract. >> Under the contract.
That's all under the >> No, but I I think the qualifiers
are very clearly No, no, that's very clearly what the >> Those
who are fans of the program, been fans for a long time. Hutch
doesn't understand what's happening right now, okay? Taylor Lorenz
and Pisco are floating like 3 ft off the ground and he is very
lost. He doesn't understand how that's happening or what they're
doing, okay? He's He is alone. He's on the ground. He's grounded.
He's a flightless bird right now, okay? He doesn't know what
what's going on here. He's lost.
He's It's It's happening again. It's happening again where everybody
else understands what's happening except for Hutch and we get
to watch him struggle with the fact that he is limited. He does
not have the capacity that everybody else does who participates
in the same sphere. >> What we're talking about is what's
allowed under the contract. Do you have any basis to believe
that's that's un >> But why wouldn't you verify that that
was being enforced? >> Wait, no, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, >> But that's why they came to talk to us. That's
why we have the article. >> But Taylor >> So they're
probably in breach. Hutch Hutch Hutch, the answer is they're
probably in breach. The answer is they're probably in breach.
>> I don't know what is in the contract versus what they
enforce. >> Rude, but the question Hutch Hutch, the question
stands. And do you have a basis? Hutch, the question stands.
Do you have a basis to believe that's untrue? Yes or no? >> The
framing of this I find >> He doesn't want to answer. He
doesn't want to answer. Don't make me answer. No. No. >> Do
you have a basis to believe the statement is untrue? >> I
I the framing is dishonest. Do you even dis >> Is the statement
Is the statement true or not? >> No, I think that's part
of the contract. But but so so >> Dude, do you even disagree
with me? Yes, you are making bad arguments. You are not being
specific in your language at all. You are this up massively.
There could be criticisms here, Hutch, but because of HOW BAD
YOU ARE at your job, you are failing to make any.
And it's embarrassing and you're a part of my show. I have a
professional connection with you. You are ruining this show
by virtue of your incompetence. >> So I So So Yeah, yeah,
I I do. I do. But it's also it's kind of like in four days kind
of like lame to just have a pile on. And, I have a different
problem with the contractual language having to do with funnel
through. And, that's been done to death. And, I I can't even
get my foot hurt on that. But, I just want to ask you, Hutch,
do you have a basis to believe that that statement in the article
is true? Yes or no? >> No, not as it's framed. No. >> You
think that they were allowed to >> have a basis you either
have a basis to believe it's false or or you don't. >> No, no,
no. Hang on. You're not saying like you're doing the slippery
thing, Taylor. Were you aware that creators had been open that
they were a part of Corus before you wrote the article? >> Um
you you can see that we actually link to Ken Bensinger's New
York Times article, I believe, uh or reference it in in the piece.
I I literally talked about that multiple time it's Corus the
the Corus itself, like the sort of broader entity that Brian
Tyler Cohen started, was the subject of a New York Times article
that was very public. So, obviously, I know that Corus was public
cuz I've also written about Corus before. So, >> Well,
then then I don't know how to make sense of the sentence the
influencers are not allowed to disclose their relationship with
Corus or >> according to contracts copies of the contract.
So, if you are signing a contract for this specific program,
Hutch, then in that case
you are not supposed to disclose your relationship. That is what
the contract
It's all about what the contract says. So, you saying, "Well,
but the people of the the related to book core." It doesn't matter
what insane psycho babble you come up with, it matters what's
in the contract because that's the claim that's made. >> their
relationship with Corus. Exactly. They couldn't disclose their
relationship with Corus or the 1630 fund or functionally that
they're related >> get to get it though. They had many
had discussed their relationship with >> I mean, but the
article is about what the contract allows. >> Guys, I know,
but >> Guys, let me step in here. You got 10 minutes left.
And, I got to say two things. And, Guy's been really incredibly
quiet. And, I think we can pivot this last thing into something
[clears throat] that Guy will really want to talk about. So,
first thing is Taylor, like I don't think Hutch is like a white
nationalist because I think you would take grievance with me
saying Joe Biden is a progressive, right? Because even if I could
describe every most progressive thing that Joe Biden did, it's
very clear
>> No. No, lots of people think Joe Bi- Dude, Joe Biden
might have had the most progressive like legislative agenda in
the past 30 years or 40 years.
Like Joe Biden had an insanely progressive legislative agenda
compared to like every other president. So easy to call him a
progressive actually.
And she might not like it, but it's so easy to accurately and
descriptively call Joe Biden a progressive. Like who who who
measures up? FDR? FDR's the more progressive president I guess.
That there's like one. There's maybe two. I think I think LBJ
is the other one that people cite. But it's like those two and
then it's there aren't any >> Clearly we're talking about
>> can I tell you something? Can I tell you I and I know
you guys aren't going to believe me on this. There are there
are way like I and I talk to people in the Biden world that do
argue that Biden was a very progressive president. Biden was
a very progressive president in a lot of ways. I actually do
think that that could be fair to describe him in that way in
certain kind >> Oh, yeah. You're you're destroyed. Yeah.
I don't know why he Why did he just walk into that? That's That's
So he builds like auto conveyor belts. You know the smashing
conveyor belt, the conveyor belt that goes to like the hammer
thing that comes down and just smash it. He's like sitting there
and he's like, "Well, this is fine. This is fine. Um would you
say that Joe Biden was a progressive? Wouldn't that really offend
you?" And he's just going to sit there on the conveyor belt and
watch his doom come towards him one stomp at a time. Five, you
know, stomp moves 3 ft. Stomp moves 3 ft. Stomp
Cool. I I guess so. >> if I was reading an article and
it described him that way in the context of some of the policies
that he pushed that were progressive, I would not take issue
with that. And I know like I said before What you are doing is
like >> Feel like someone should do it. Like Joe Biden's
like the great Satan for like his COVID policies, right? Like
you really just like but he's like >> Wow. I would not
call him Satan, but I would say that he adopted far right >> Genocidal
policies on disabled people. >> Okay, that one. >> Taylor,
I don't know if she has to disclose her bias on
like politics or her friendship with Hasan or anything like that.
She might have to disclose her bias in terms of COVID and and
you know uh pathogens. >> On certain and I would say Israel
and
>> Well, on Israel and and some other things, sure. >> Okay,
hold on. I was trying not to fight anymore cuz I I I know you've
said this >> I I I don't agree with Joe Biden at all. I
think he's a I I did not like him as president. Do I think he's
better than Trump? Yes. But but but listen. No, but oh, if I
was writing an article, for instance, and we're not talking about
my YouTube videos or Twitter. If I want to pop off and say whatever
I want about Joe Biden. But if I'm writing an article and I'm
seeking to be factu- factually accurate, and I call someone a
liberal or a centrist or progressive, whatever, and that goes
through all these other editors, by the way, often who add, you
know, sort of own, whatever. We're we're trying our best to get
things accurate. I I'm not going to put like genocidal Joe Biden
or whatever in an article that is like a fact-checked investigative
article. I wouldn't. I would be like Joe Biden who has executed
XYZ policies or whatever. And with me characterizing Olivia Juliana
as a centrist who spoke at the DNC, Hutch, I know you think that
that's supposed to be some like neg on her or something. I clearly
I should have used the term liberal who spoke at the DNC and
maybe that would have triggered you less. But it's not I I like
and I'm not saying that I haven't been critical of centrists.
What I'm saying is like I think that's a very silly point to
like take with this article because I think it's not only is
it completely irrelevant to the broader topic of the article,
but it's like I think you're describing a lot of motivation to
what is ultimately like a pretty meaningless descriptor that
I don't even think is very >> know if it was meaningless.
I I I think you were you were telling a larger narrative. I don't
think it was I don't think it was primarily about disclosure.
I think it was about anti-establishment and then, you know, the
the corrupt like >> Well, they are pro-establishment. They
are pro-establishment. >> guy. You've said this before,
and Taylor, I think you might have a very strong opinion on this.
There is so much dark money coming in from the right, like unfathomably.
1630 was the answer to that. >> other Wired article that
came out on >> I Oh, yeah. No, yeah, by the way, yeah.
We'll plug this at the end. Uh your your other um >> I'm
just going to take issue with that. You're going to you're going
to like the >> you back on another argument. >> We're
not anti-AI. We just want to help the AI into We're not pro-AI.
>> He's seething. He's seething.
HE'S SEETHING. [screaming] DUDE, TAYLOR keeps Taylor keeps holding
W's, man. I can't even. It's so funny to watch her do this stuff.
It's so funny. I see the steam. The steam's It's out of his ears
right now. I can see it. >> by Palantir and Open AI. We're
not pro >> Who's this guy? >> Listen, I I Let me
finish. Guy, you said we need to use dark money to fight dark
money. You know, all all bets are off at this point. Why not
fight fire with fire? What's your take on that essentially? And
then Taylor, I want you to respond to like Guy's kind of like
overall broad point of fight fire with fire. >> We're just
getting our ass kicked over on the left with the flooding of
dark money. We found out Clovicky alert. >> Dude, did I
I Dude, I already knew everything Guy was going to say. Before
IRI really said he hates anybody who stops Democrats from getting
money. Democrats are not getting as much money as Republicans.
Anybody who says Democrats shouldn't get more money or does anything
to stand in the way of that is the enemy and them. And I don't
even care what the the the truth is of the matter. If you're
stopping me from getting money, you. You're stopping Democrats
from getting money, you. You're stopping left-aligned people
from getting money in in social media, you. That's That's IRI.
That's how IRI works. >> Or it's funded by Peter Thiel.
I mean >> That's not true. Peter Thiel doesn't like Clovicky
alert. I don't know where that came from. You know he's funded
by an Israeli billionaire right now. >> Okay, let me let
me ask you a question then, Taylor. Because I've heard that you're
a big fan of Hasan and you said that you're critical of everybody
including left. So, what is one criticism of Hasan that you have?
>> Could you say something bad about Hasan for us, Taylor?
Could you say something bad about Hasan?
So, I I really hope that she just says, "Actually, I think that'd
be really inappropriate." Oh, hold on. Hasan's bad. Hasan's bad.
Hasan's bad. Hasan's bad. Hasan's bad.
That's five. Okay, we're taking a break from that for a second.
Okay? It's
She should just say, "Hasan's my friend. I know you guys don't
like him. I'm not going to sit here and talk [__]
about him in front of you cuz it's just weird for you to ask
that in the first place. Apropos of nothing." If you had something
where I hadn't criticized him or something, like if you if you
brought up something where I didn't criticize him sufficiently,
which I'm sure there are points, right? Then go ahead. But if
you're just going to say, "What's a criticism I have of him?"
That's inappropriate. I'm not going to go I'm not going to go
on a podcast where a bunch of people dislike my friend and then
you're they're going to say, "What do you dislike about your
friend?" And I'm going to pop off. Like, go go get the [__]
out of here. No. Weird weird question.
You get a journalist to come on who's getting published in a
bunch of big a bunch of big magazines. She is riding high in
her career right now. She is taking time out of her day to come
on your show and you go, "Um could you give me a criticism of
Hasan? Thank you. Thank you." I am managing in 30 seconds what
took Hutch an hour and a half totally tanking the reputation
of his own podcast. Fantastic stuff, man. Very not embarrassing
for you. >> Just to dispel this notion that you're in the
Hasan camp. Cuz I've heard this a lot and I'm just trying to
get this it doesn't sound like it. So, I want to give you a chance
to say what you've been critical of Hasan for. >> I think
one thing that Hasan could do better and I'm sympathetic to a
>> Too nice. She's too nice to talk to these people in
the first place. I've no idea how she hasn't gotten like ground
into hamburger doing these podcasts, going on Destiny's stream.
I've no idea how she hasn't gotten ground into hamburger for
being good faith and answering that she is really she should
never answer.
she somehow keeps doing it. I just feel like it's it's going
to work out badly at some point when she answers these >> am
on the left and I think I actually think Hasan gets a lot of
like bad faith attacks. So, I'm mostly defending him. I think
one thing he could do better is speak about
issues on specific policies. I think he focuses a lot on foreign
policy. I think he doesn't focus enough on tech policy, on other,
you know, policy areas that I think he could do a lot of good
in and I think that he focuses a lot more on sort of these bigger
issues that maybe get a lot more attention and that's his job
as a content creator. But, I yeah, I think he kind of big boys
>> gave him an ear. That was that's going to get clipped.
Hasan's going to not be your friend anymore after you said that
really awful mean thing to him. >> Well, everything I say
I will say to people's faces as well. And I but to and to your
point by the way about the dark money stuff, just because Clavicular
isn't currently as far as we can tell funded by dark money, I
that doesn't mean that I don't >> The funny thing is is
like that's probably the exact one that they never would have
dreamt they'd get out of her. Right? I think that's like exactly
the take they would have wanted that they never would have dreamed
they'd get from from her and she just gives it and moves
And it's like whatever. I I personally wouldn't have but I I
understand why she did. >> should do like
that is a very legitimate argument to have cuz Peter Thiel is
funding a lot of people on the >> you know I have another
question too is
what does disclosure look like? For example, I did an event with
America recently and I told my channel they paid for my flight.
I paid for my hotel, my parking, my food, everything. They paid
for my flight but like I feel like the goal post keeps moving
on disclosure. So, what does disclosure look like that is satisfactory
to you? >> Uh literally the line here should just be the
um what the F uh the FTC FTC regulations, right? On disclosures
for paid advertising.
That should be the line.
Super easy, already exists, works pretty well, right? Whatever
it is for advertisements when you when you're giving an opinion
or you're sponsored on a product, you have to let people know
that. Whatever the disclosure requirement is there, minimum for
politics. Maybe there should even be something beyond that for
politics, but it should be if you are getting sponsored at all,
you should have to say it. It should like if you have some politically
aligned group that's giving you money and then they go, "Well,
you don't have to really like say anything specific." That's
not an excuse not to
Okay? You're being paid for your opinion, just put just like
these guys do, right? When these guys say, "Hey, what these guys
have to do transparent reporting?" Same thing. >> I bring
it up because these guys make the big boys like Hasan make a
lot of money. They don't need to take any funding. They don't
need any help. And smaller creators, it's you know how it is,
it's tough and to do this even part-time can be expensive and
you know, it's rare to make money and so I I just think it's
it's in my opinion
>> Okay? So, they shouldn't disclose cuz they're smaller
and they don't really make money. So, you should just let them
Like I'm fine dude, it's totally fine. Take the money and then
just explain, "Here's who I take money from." "These guys paid
for a part of my channel." You could You could do the whole spiel
about how it doesn't actually affect your opinions and your opinions
haven't changed at all. You do that whole spiel for your audience.
Just be transparent about it. Embarrassing. >> harsh on
people who are just trying to get a little help. They're not
trying to hide anything. They're just looking for help and and
it was offered to them, you know. >> And and like I said,
I have friends that are taking help from these programs and I
don't want that to discourage that. I don't. What I want is really
for the people that run these programs to >> Oh, that The
great question there is why does it discourage them, IRA?
Hey Hey, IRA, why are they discouraged by the idea of transparency
or the idea of disclosure?
Why would that discourage them? And if there's something there,
if there's something going on that they're feeling discouraged
or demotivated by,
shouldn't we unpack that? Shouldn't we see Cuz what I think it
is is they don't like that they're going to be called a shill
or something. It's like, well, but you are. You you're taking
money from a group with a certain
And everybody there is always something in the back of your head.
Don't listen to anybody who ever tells you differently. There
is always something in the back of your head that will limit
you or change how you think about things based on how much money
you're taking. Anybody who tells you differently is lying to
you.
>> Yeah, I've linked your article below in the description
about this the Palantir and this I I read it. I think this is
frankly kind of scary that you can just label anything an ad
and this is your paid propaganda. You don't have to say where
it's coming from or you know, what the agenda is. So yeah, everyone
please go check out Taylor's new article. Um but anything else
Taylor that you're shouting out, any appearances, any um books?
I mean, I I didn't even know you'd written a book. Uh but yeah.
>> Well, I think people probably know what I'm going to
say, which is we have to
>> these identity verification laws and mass surveillance.
We didn't talk about it. It's so frustrating that on a live and
learn podcast that we are witnessing the decimation of our rights,
of our civil liberties under a fascist
>> I thought you she said that. It's unfortunate they're
not talking about it, but it sounds like she's blaming these
guys for destroying their rights to privacy.
Which, you know,
realistically, if it's about beating Trump, this was not a good
showing for these guys. I
>> Hey, listen, I didn't think I could get into a place
where I might be supporting Maga, but this this podcast right
here
>> That's obviously a joke. Obviously a joke. We don't
like Trump. Obviously I have not called for tribunals for anybody
in this podcast. >> is rolling back on free speech protections
at a at a rate that we that we have never seen in our lifetimes.
It should horrify people. And um you know, there's no discussion
of that on this podcast it seems like and it's really frustrating
especially to have a tech journalist on here who covers who does
so much reporting who dedicates my life to covering this stuff
and you guys want to litigate whether I called an influencer
a centrist in an article I wrote a year and a half ago. >> Taylor,
I told you please stop it. You know, we talked about it. We just
talked >> this I'm talking about this podcast. I'm talking
about this podcast. I want every single person that listens to
this podcast to go right now to stop
and fight back against this the censorship and surveillance laws.
It's terrifying. We have um laws right now the Guard Act in Congress
that um you know, is ostensibly cracking down on AI that's not
cracking down on AI. It's just removing anonymity from the internet
and it's it's devastating. It's horrible. >> All right.
Well, thank you so much for coming on Taylor. I'm going to let
you go. We're going to do our little wrap up here, but last question,
do you now acknowledge that Hutch is not Dan
>> Okay, I I do need to be able to tell the difference
between the two and I'm really sorry.
>> Well, you guys say a lot of the same
>> Wait, really? Sorry, that's a that's very funny. Hutch
does not like that. Hutch does not like that at all. I don't
know how she thought that, but that's very funny. >> Oh
gosh. All right, thank you Taylor. Pleasure and >> I have
seen you I will remember it in my >> I Let me just say
I just you know, I do I do appreciate um I respect the fact that
you came in here and you agreed to that exchange and you know,
I do respect that. I do Again, I want to reiterate that I appreciate
the fact that you are calling attention to like the the the issue
of money and politics and disclosure. I think it does matter
and I think we need we need journalists that are covering these
things and so I'll try to be as graceful as I can at the end
of this, but I I I respect you coming on and >> It's fine.
We can agree to disagree, but thank you for shouting out. Everybody
go to stoponlineidchecks.org
and I'll see you guys there. >> All right, Taylor. Thank
you. >> Okay, bye guys. Bye.
>> All right. Well, that was an episode of Living Learning.
How How do we all feel about that? >> the books.
>> I mean, I think the centrist point is stupid. That's
just my foot view. I I have issues with the contractual
um of the through thing, but um I didn't feel like those were
aired. I just think like calling the centrist or not it's like
>> It was just indicative of the of the slant, right? It
was It was what Hush was trying to point this as like a >> the
title The title is the best >> Yeah, sure. >> Let's
focus on the title. Yeah. The title and and then the the tweet
which you did which was good. Um >> Let me Please go. If
you were to steelman, like what larger point do you think I was
making? >> No, no. I understand the point about like bias
and stuff, but the factual accuracy point That's what I thought
was >> It wasn't about bias. >> Well, sure it was.
>> No, it's not about It's not about bias. It's about I
She claimed that her article was about disclosure, and I think
her article was about something more meta than that. I think
she was She was painting a narrative or writing a narrative about
the big bad establishment, the corrupt
>> Yeah, he basically said just argue this point and then
give your evidence alongside it. Don't try to argue what centrist
means cuz that is by far the worst piece of evidence. That is
what he's saying. That you gave the worst piece of evidence and
you spent the most time allocated to arguing it. Peace Sorry,
Hutch. That is what he's telling you. You took all of the time
arguing something that is not germane to the conversation you
want to have. >> centrist pro-Israel shills and the virtuous
like leftists that were suppressed and frozen out of this >> Right,
but that's what I'm saying. It's It's circumstantial evidence
to get >> her state of mind and this nefarious intent.
And that is exhibited by her um using that terminology. But what
I have an issue with is like disputing the factual accuracy of
it. I mean, that's just like [__] stupid in my mind.
I don't think that it's useful to >> agree that that's
what she was doing with that article? >> Um I don't disagree
that that's what she was doing with that with the article, in
fact. And I don't disagree that the the title says it all and
that's the framing. Yeah. >> is pejorative and she was
using it as a >> No, no, no. But you were disputing the
the factual accuracy of that claim. You understand the difference?
>> I understand the point about the framing. I agree with
you on the framing. But the fact of the actual point I think
is stupid. >> She said she didn't insert her opinion. She
clearly did a number of times throughout that article. And that
was one of those times.
factual accuracy of the claim. You understand the difference?
I understand the point about the framing. I agree with you on
the framing. But the fact of the actual point I think is stupid.
>> She said she didn't insert her opinion. She clearly
did a number of times throughout that article. And that was one
of those times.
She literally told you from the very beginning that that's how
Olivia Juliana described herself. That's what she told you. >> This
wasn't intentional
Are you hearing me, Hutch? I'm not saying that she didn't have
opinion and the framing was absolutely biased in ways that you've
called out. What I'm
>> The point of the editorial staff, by the way, also is
to remove that that framing. Remove that bias. That's the point
of the editorial staff, right? Is there supposed to make it so
that that bias that she might have doesn't come through? They
all looked at that. They didn't care about that that framing.
One, because it's not relevant to the rest of the article. Whether
they put progressive or centrist there, it doesn't matter.
And he's disputing the factual accuracy of it. That's what I
think is dumb. Like Biden calls himself a centrist, you know?
He He says, "I'm a centrist
She was a She was a She was a She was a She was a executive like
director at a progressive like think tank, you know? Like she
>> You were trying to dispute whether or not she was in
fact centrist.
That was the white the white nationalist
But but
>> She No, no, listen. She avoided the point that I was
making. She avoided it like the plague. So much so that she was
willing to call a >> He thinks he won. He thinks he He
thinks he won. He thinks he did a good job. He thinks he
He thinks he did a good job. He actually thinks he did a good
job.
He thinks he did a good job. He thinks he won. He thinks he did
a good
Okay. That just that feeling I described about wanting to smash
a keyboard, it just spiked massively, okay? It's a massive corty
spike. You don't know this about me, but when I'm actually upset,
I get very quiet and very calm, okay?
Most of the time I'm yelling on the stream is for show.
max maximum cortisol levels right now, okay? It's it's over for
me. >> AOC and Bernie as centrists. I mean, give me >> That's
great. >> That was ridiculous. She's she's The thing is,
I think it's more effective to un- to underscore what she is
in fact saying. If you underscore the fact that all you mean
by centrist is Democrat-aligned,
well then trivially, right? That would make um anybody who's
aligned with course a centrist. >> That's because then
that would make AOC and Bernie a centrist. It's totally >> Okay,
so that I think that that's more effective than trying to like
>> I mean, sure, that could be a better way to argue it,
but I don't think she thinks I think she I think she would argue
those people are like more or less outside of the party
I do think what she said about Biden Her one point was bad, but
she's trying to argue something that she shouldn't even be arguing.
It should have She should have just cut the conversation off.
The second you go, "Oh, well, why did you use this word?" Oh,
that's how she described herself.
Oh, no, I I didn't even think about it. It's not relevant to
the article.
No, I like I didn't think about it. Nobody flagged it. We didn't
care. It's not relevant to the article. Doesn't change anything
whether we call her progressive or centrist. You're trying to
make some broader point, which you could make basically on her
post post-article interviews. But you guys didn't want to do
that. You were lazy. You brought up one thing that was stupid.
And you just kept trying to make the same point. That could,
by the way, be accurate. She could have let her bias through
in that article, but you guys did the worst job imaginable attempting
to show it. Like a shameful shameful display.
>> Assess out whether you know the the in fact accuracy
of the centrism from some objective stance independent way. I
think that that is just like an exercise in futility. And it
makes it I think it makes a critique not land as much. If you
focus on the title, I think in the tweet or whatever. And also
like just the structure of it, you know, it wasn't my favorite.
I I I felt bad for IRI, you know, but um But you you know, I
I have issues with the with the piece and I did at the time and
still do, frankly. I don't think there is a satisfying answer
on the methodology point that you were that we both raised on
the Israel stuff. Like how are you deciphering whether or not
these creators are pro-Israel or not? And it's their lack of
comment on genocide and it's a subset of a subset and you that
should have been obvious. I mean, yeah, that's that's what I
mean by I think the focus on like the weak criticisms and I think
a weak criticism is the factual accuracy of the Centrist point.
The weak criticism I think is also the whether the contract forbade
the disclosure or not when there doesn't any evidence that the
contract does not forbid the disclosure and they have lawyers
who are looking at it and so I trust that it probably does. That's
what frustrates me and that's why I'm you >> Well, I mean
like it's so so again it says like according to the contract
and then it starts with like they're forbidden from disclosing
their relationship with Coors or the 1630 Fund. But but if she
was already aware that influencers had previously you know discussed
their relationship with Coors and so clearly >> they're
in breach Hutch. That means they're in breach. >> Or it's
not being enforced. Wait, hold on. There's a There's a difference
between There's a difference
the letter of a contract and whether or not it's actually being
enforced. >> I Oh, I understand that. Yes, I understand
that. >> it's an it's a journalist's job to suss that out
and to confirm that the letter of the contract is being enforced.
And she didn't do that and she could have.
the one thing I'm saying that she's not >> We could go
so far on this. The point is that you agree with us that there
is an ideological slant to the she is >> 100% That was
my Do you guys forget me debating this? Do you forget me debating
this issue and me having the stance I do? But the thing is I
think the structure of it is of the interrogation aspect of it.
I didn't like it and I thought some of the points that we were
dwelling on were stupid. And I did feel the need to speak up
when I felt that there were parts of the the the the article
that were just factually accurate and that were just like literally
true. And that is >> indisputably true that Hutch was He
doesn't understand. He literally can't understand.
Doesn't get it. Doesn't get it. Just doesn't understand.
>> That's the same thing that drives me crazy and I'm always
going to speak up on that when I hear that. One last thing I'll
say is yeah, in general I think we all agree on on somewhat of
the disclosure aspect. We all criticize these right rightoids
when they all like congregate and don't disclose all this this
going on. I think that point should be taken in good stride and
we should encourage people like Brian and David who I think who
I respect, who I like to do like this and I think Course is based
and I think that they should be funding dark money groups to
support >> That was my take, man. Just like I'm so psyched
that Course exists. It's good that it exists.
Just manage your PR better. Like just don't be a How hard is
it to just like just do the Google thing? Just don't be evil.
Don't be shitty. Literally just be like, "Hey, dude, it's
Just don't be shitty.
Just don't attack somebody who's like basically pointing out
issues with your contract setup. And then respond to the article,
man. >> for Democrats all over the place.
>> Well, I'm still shocked at her scathing criticism of
Hassan there. I I don't think I've ever heard someone get taken
down so hard. >> I can't believe she said something so
awful about him there. >> That was He's going to be pissed.
Holy
And I I think that said a lot in her answer there. But I She
got awfully defensive. I don't know what's the story there. I
did not follow the Course thing as closely as you guys, obviously.
That's why I stayed out of it. I didn't dare try to change the
subject or interject. You guys just seem like you're you're doing
something and you're [__] >> He IRI just doesn't
need to IRI doesn't even He doesn't want to know. It's better
for IRI not to know because if IRI read into it and then realized
that his side was in the wrong, it would be harder for him to
argue around it. He doesn't want to know. All he's going to say
is, "Dems not getting money, bad. You not letting Dems get money,
bad. You >> focused on it, which is fine. But boy, she
was super defensive. And I don't know about you, but I'm proud
to like talk about whatever I do, you know? I'm not getting
hurt. She's >> Okay, this is this isn't crazy sweeping.
She came on to talk. She She was open about all the stuff that
was going on. She was defensive on what was it? Like basically
the idea that oh you had to name people who are pro-Israel who
are part of Chorus. And she's like, "No, I'm Cuz probably most
of the people she knows are people she talked to, right? And
so to start naming people is going to start like risking talk
naming people she talked to. And so she's saying, "No, no, no,
I'm not going to do that." Now, she could be hiding behind those
people to not have to disclose that basically she didn't mostly
interview people who are pro-Israel or something. That's
But just like once it reaches a deadlock, I don't even know what
you do at that point. >> Seem like genuinely pissed at
>> Did you disclose that I purchased that hat for you?
>> Uh you gave it to me. >> Uh so >> That I
used. >> you mean with money? >> I also find the
um the minimization of the concerns really really silly as well.
Like it You are trying to have a serious conversation and now
you just had her on. Why would you even have her on and then
go, "Wasn't the reporting like isn't even being concerned about
this kind of silly in the first place?" Did you disclose that
I got you that gift, I right? Did you disclose that? It's People
don't think about how they look to other people.
I did Listen, and if that's not the pot calling the kettle black,
I say some sometimes I don't think about it at all, okay? But
I'm just I'm putting it out cuz these guys seem like they want
to try to be a little more professional than I am with my little
penguin, my little guy, and I just do a bunch of jokes on the
stream, okay? They seem like they want to be more politically
activated, politically involved, and it's just like probably
if you want to do that, you should be thinking about these things,
no? He's going to laughing. Well, it's not It's like it It's
And I I don't know, maybe Soy Boy doesn't get this and maybe
they just feel like this is Soy, but you're like undermining
the guest you just had on, right? You're saying this isn't a
very big deal, that it's kind of silly to even be upset about
it. That is the message you're communicating, and you're doing
it after she left, which is another thing that you're communicating,
right? That you're like mocking after she left. You're saying
everything everything is a signal, everything's information.
>> Well, where do you think Where do you think I got it?
You think it just I manifest these hats? They just grow out of
my head? No, I paid for that. You got a a bribe from me. >> Thank
you for the sweaty hat off your >> I wasn't sweating that
day. I made sure I got a clean one. All right, guys. What's going
on this week? What are we What are we boosting, Hutch? What are
you doing? >> Just regular stream. Thanks you guys for
tuning in. I you know >> Uh they left her on a note of
capitulating to the concern about it and then made fun of her
concern immediately after. Yeah, they did. They're like, "Listen,
all this stuff, disclosing money, it's all important and and
you know, it's important it's important conversation to have."
Then she leaves. Hey, did you disclose that I got you that hat?
>> I did do like literally like 12 hours of prep and there
were there were so many other things, but we kept getting stuck
>> 12 hours of prep? 12 hours of prep and that was the
result?
12 hours of prep for that shameful
dis play? That shameful dis play is It was just like awful. It
was awful content. Well,
for anybody who wants to watch politics, it's awful content.
For people who want to watch productive conversations, it's awful
content. For people who want to watch a total train wreck and
often watch lolcows in total train wrecks, like me,
well, that was great. Thank you so much, Hutch. You You just
filled up like 4 hours of my stream with with that dis with that
disgraceful performance.
So, it's awesome. Thank you.